which called for all necessary measures
to protect libyan civilians from the
forces of muammar qaddafi in february
2011 libya changed for the wars other
arab countries such as tunisia egypt and
yemen in the previous months had
experienced political turmoil western
media quickly labeled these uprisings as
the arab spring they took for granted
that it was a sort of revolution against
repression and dictatorships i suppose a
better name would be the arab autumn
anyway the trigger of the riots began in
tunisia with the suicide of a poor
street vendor who set himself on fire
because he couldn't stand the constant
harassment by the local police in cairo
instead the protests in tahrir square
against the mubarak government came from
the youngest who blamed corruption and
unemployment the vast majority of people
had three simple demands social justice
work and the possibility of living a
normal life in libya the situation was
initially the same but the reasons that
led to the civil war were quite
different in 2011 libya had a very
distinct political situation from
tunisia and egypt although ruled by an
authoritarian and highly questionable
leader muhammad gaddafi
libya's mold population only six
millions people enjoyed a decent
standard of living better than one might
have thought even better than yemen or
lebanon the oil and gas industry had
absorbed most of the skilled workforce
and people allowing the nation to enjoy
most of the profits how was it possible
simple with a strong control by gaddafi
keeping a tight control on political and
economic issues through a system of
loyalty built over the years with
alliances nepotism and money muhammad
gaddafi managed to maintain power for an
extraordinarily long period of time from
1969. in that year gaddafi or as he was
called the race proclaimed with the
kudata the beginning of the arab
republic of libya after surviving
several attacks by the us in the 80s
gaddafi gradually normalized his
relation with the west and by the early
2000s he was seen as a tough head of
state some european leaders even
tolerated him with an unwritten pact you
don't give us any trouble with migrants
and we'll just leave you alone so at
that time in libya there weren't
significant riots and the popular
descent was limited to some extremist
elements anyway the tunisian and
egyptian revolts had convinced one of
the arab gulf countries qatar that was
possible to overthrow gadhafi's power
from the outside by relying on the help
of moderate islamic forces in libya the
emirate of qatar presented itself to the
world as a country in favor of the fall
of the north african dictatorships so to
gain an area of influence in the region
the reason was pretty simple to stand
out and prevail against its nemesis
saudi arabia while saudi arabia was
traditionally protecting radical and
ultra-conservative islamist forces such
as the wahhabis and salafists doa
supported and financed more moderate and
actively committed islamic
fundamentalist groups like the muslim
brotherhood in egypt
a fringe group that saudi arabia or the
united arab emirates had always
considered an existential threat
february 16 and 17 aka the days of wrath
as they were called were completely
unexpected especially in the eyes of
many analysts who knew that libya was
one of the most stable states in the
region even gaddafi was taken by
surprise and reacted with confusion
everything started in the east in
srinayaka in the city of benghazi it was
very clear that the events that were
happening in the east of cyrenaica were
something different from a simple revolt
and much more complex than a simple
local insurrection this was proven by
facts such as the coordinated actions
and the large availability of weapons
that circulated things that clearly
demonstrated the presence of a plan at
the base of everything we shouldn't
underestimate the quick reactions of
some european governments in particular
the french and british who instantly
supported the rebels more specifically
former french president nicolas sarkozy
had been convinced by his personal
advisor and friend bernard levy that in
libya with the rise of the so-called
arab spring there was a window of
opportunity to overthrow gaddafi's as
well an opportunity that could have
offered the french access to a very rich
market for both the energy and military
sectors on tv newspapers and radios a
narrative began to spread around the
libyan crisis based on the logic that
gaddafi's regime was repressing in blood
a peaceful and popular revolt this
narrative began spreading from qatar
which broadcasted images of violence
destruction anger and death in a
systematic manner to the point of
convincing european public opinion that
gaddafi had unleashed a massacre with
the aim of maintaining his power and
privileges the qatari news described how
the libyan air force indiscriminately
bombed the urban eras of sirenica
creating thousands of victims among
civilians beyond this the media spoke of
mercenaries under gadhafi's payroll who
were stuffed with viagra and were guilty
of raids and rapes against the
population something that actually
wasn't proven at all
so as you watch the videos tonight and
watch the programs tonight ask yourself
this who do you believe a dictator's
words or your own eyes and ears
ironically however most libyans
refrained from participating in the
uprisings they basically feared reprisal
from the regime their passiveness
allowed gaddafi's troops to recapture
most of the country in a few weeks and
move quickly towards benghazi to crush
the rebellion once and for all faced
with an almost certain defeat the rebels
of sinaika requested the military
intervention of the west on march of the
same year a hesitant nato as well as an
even more reluctant united states were
involved in a brief but significant
mission operation odyssey dawn the
libyan air force was wiped out and
qadhafi forces were stopped before
entering benghazi according to
unofficial sources there would have been
an agreement between nato the united
arab emirates and qatar before starting
the raid an agreement signed only one
day before qatar acknowledged the
official nature of the cnt there is the
national council of transition against
gaddafi according to sam uae involvement
in libya for example would allow abu
dhabi to deepen its strategic relations
with france others said that qatar was
prone to agree because it could benefit
from exclusive access to some of the
libyan oil reserves they would trade it
on behalf of the new libyan government
that would have risen after gaddafi but
qatar was hardly the only voice in the
oil business already in april 2011
french companies expressed their
willingness to settle in the country as
revealed by the state department in 2016
some emails found in the servers of
hillary clinton the us secretary of
state at that time and open supporter of
the uprisings referred to alleged french
humanitarian flights to libya to which
groups of executives from two major
french companies total and dinsi
actually traveled as stated by a close
clinton advisor in one of these emails
french intelligence agents had described
sarkozy's interest in libya as being
based on the desire to obtain a greater
share of oil production gaddafi didn't
behave well against westerners gaddafi
first reacted by interrupting any
collaboration with western oil companies
in libya to protect his fields which
resulted in a 30 increase in the price
of natural gas this of course deeply
worried the main nature powers first and
foremost france great britain and the us
on the other hand as officially stated
by alan jupit the french foreign
minister at that time it was right and
logical that french companies could
defend their position and benefit from
the war in libya according to the french
newspaper liberation speculation about
the real motivations for the french
intervention were based on a letter that
rebel forces had sent to sarkozy in
april 2011. the rebels offered france 35
of libya's oil and gas in exchange for
french support for the insurgency as we
can well imagine that was a way not only
for france but also for other european
powers to reduce their dependence on
russian gas imports in the email
unclassified number 2014 2043.9 called
the french client and gaddafi's gold
sent in april 2011 by a close clinton
aide sydney blumenthal the main
motivation for the french attack was
endorsed by the white house and was
totally hidden to other allies such as
italy or germany according to the report
france had attacked libya because
gadhafi's short-term intention was to
replace the african franc the cfa in the
french african territories with a new
local currency the email in short term
was that gaddafi's large reserves of
gold and silver estimated to be 143 tons
were a real danger for the survival of
the cfa franc itself a new currency
could have given the countries of the
francophone africa an alternative with
which to achieve economic independence
from france it was for this reason that
the air bombings of the joint military
intervention from qatar france and
british royal air force crushed
gaddafi's naval and air defenses
resulting in the collapse of key
strongholds for the regime such as
tripoli and certi cities in which
qadhafi on the run had been hiding for
some time surrounded by the rebels in
october gaddafi tried to escape through
the desert but military drones sent by
the obama administration intercepted
this convoy the rest of the story is
history a story rather bloody and well
known qadhafi was captured by the rebels
knee capped raped with a wooden stick
and executed with a gunshot to the head
all this was recorded and stored on
video only at that point nato stopped
operating and abandoning labia to its
destiny
but once the old master gaddafi was dead
the race for the libyan resources had
just begun u.s sources stressed to the
various departments the importance of
not allowing countries such as turkey or
italy to invade the field designated for
u.s france and qatar the death of
gaddafi aroused the mixed reactions in
libya there were those who rejoiced
those who were still attached to the
memory of the old leader and those who
knew that the future crisis would make
the old regime be regretted what
resulted from the fall of gaddafi was
dictated by the historical dualism that
separated tsrinika and tripolitania a
polarization that led to a de facto
separation in two of libya with the rise
of islamist groups and small local gangs
around 300 of them and with a breakup of
the old alliances between the various
tribes in the southern part of the
country libya turned into anarchy where
no one was actually in power anymore and
where everyone had its own interest
history teaches us that libya has been
torn by two civil wars the first ended
with the death of gaddafi in october
2011 and the second began in 2014 and
still ongoing the truth is that the war
has never ended it always went on and
from the arab spring libya moved to the
arab winter on one hand there were the
national forces loyal to general after
who had settled down in cyronaica in
tobruk he soon stood out as the strong
man in charge with the claim that the
general national congress mandate was
expired after was backed and financed by
the united arab emirates egypt saudi
arabia france syria and russia on the
other hand there was a whole series of
various forces in tripolitania under the
umbrella of the government of national
accord whose ex-prime minister al-saraj
was accused by haftar of terrorism from
2012 this side was supported by turkey
the us and the european union basically
al-saraj blamed after for his purpose to
bring back a qadhafi style regime a long
stalemate to control the main oil
deposit followed the first phase of war
until 2012 when peace talks began with
the commitment to stabilize the country
obviously terrorist organizations such
as isis and al qaeda have entered the
libyan chaos and this didn't make it any
easier to solve the conflict with the
demise of gaddafi organized crime has
taken even greater advantage of weapon
trafficking and migratory flows from
sub-saharan africa to europe creating a
very profitable business prior to the
revolution libya boasted africa's
largest oil reserves oil which once
accounted for 96 of the country's income
is now just a memory from a peak of at
least 1.5 million barrels a day before
the war libya is now lucky if it can
export a quarter of that today libya is
in a very serious state personally i can
only hope for the best for a nation that
geopolitically is fundamental for the
stability not only for north africa but
also for europe the old libyan motto
used to be freedom and unity well let's
hope again that it will become so again
as soon as possible